part of why the coding more often
happens with supporting characters is
because not as much time is going to be
spent with them as the main characters
and more characterization shortcuts is
kind of to be expected now before I
start naming names and pissing everyone
off I am begging you to not confuse gay
coded with openly gay and indisputably
gay character gay coded characters are
often not confirmed to actually be gay
in fact in many instances their
sexuality is never addressed at all but
they still carry the coding regardless a
few examples would include the
cross-dressing pleakly from Lilo and
Stitch the squeeing clawhauser from
zootopia Lenny from Shark Tale being all
out of place in the Macho world of his
family tingle from The Legend of Zelda
games because of
well whatever this is and even the two
male parent Dynamic of the Lion King's
Timon and Pumba also fun fact Puma's
actually modeled on a female warthog not
a male one